speaking of movies very smooth you know  a movie don't mean a thing if it ain't  got that swing Oh March the walls  Oh minuet rag or rock or Bop so if you  want to score with the movie you better  have a good one  the nominees for best achievement and  Original Score are Indiana Jones John  Williams Randy Newman for the natural  Maurice Jarre for a Passage to India  john williams for the river  Alex North for under the volcano  and the winner is the winner is Maurice  Jarre for Passage to India  I was lucky Mozart was not eligible this  year  I thank all the Academy but especially  my colleagues composer who nominated  nominated me this year of the music  branch thank you very much David thank  you for the first time and just all my  friends all over the world from  Australia to Italy by France England  thank you thank you everybody  you